at the start of the movie a high
schooler named ayaki wakes up next to a
handsome boy named yosuke and 10 other
students in an unfamiliar house it turns
out that they have been kidnapped by a
mysterious organization as the teens try
to wrap their heads around their
surroundings the TV in the room turns on
and tells them that they must play a
dangerous werewolf game it is a
slaughtering game that lets the players
kill each other some of the teens
suggest running away but they learn that
the kidnapper is put on an irremovable
collar around each of their necks which
can strangle them to death should they
break the rules or resist to play after
everyone comes to terms with the
situation the TV starts announcing the
rules of the game the students will be
divided into teams with the first one
being the werewolves three students will
be chosen as the werewolves and their
job is to finish off the rest of the
group then there are eight villagers
their only job is to find the werewolves
and kill them via a voting system lastly
there is one fox who has to conceal
their identity at all costs by the end
of the game if the Fox survives all the
other students will die automatically
hence the only way for the fox to win is
by gaining others trust and staying out
of trouble between the hours of 10 pm
and 6 a.m the villagers must stay in
their rooms while the three werewolves
can roam around the house and choose one
villager to kill but if they cannot kill
someone all three werewolves will die
among the villagers there are three
special cards one bouncer one prophet
and one medium the prophet can pick
someone each night and discover if that
person is a villager or a werewolf the
bouncer can protect one person each
night from a werewolf attack but not
themself every night before 8 PM all
players must vote for a person who they
think is a werewolf the person with the
highest number of votes will have to die
and after the person's death the medium
can see if the dead player was a village
or a werewolf but if the players fail to
vote before 8 PM they will all die if
all three werewolves are killed the
villagers win but if the number of
villagers and werewolves becomes equal
the werewolves win if the fox is still
alive at the time when the villagers
exterminate all the werewolves or when
the number of villagers and werewolves
become equal the fox will become the
sole winner but if the prophet detects
the fox that ladder will die instantly
the winners of the game will receive a
cash prize of one million dollars they
should all get one million dollars for
having to sit through all those rules
after the instructions are over everyone
has given their cards and ayaki is
revealed to be the fox in the washroom
ayaki's classmate Ozawa tries to talk to
her about a game but strangely hayaki is
fixated on a crush she has developed on
yosuke one of the boys in the game later
the players introduced themselves to
each other given the profits power to
detect the werewolf Reiki the oldest
member of the group urges the prophet to
come forward so that the bouncer can
protect him or her however four people
including the fox ayaki claimed to be
the prophet failing to reach a
conclusion the players returned to their
respective rooms shortly after some of
the players venture outside and try to
find a way to escape but sadly a board
clearly mentions that if they cross the
Forbidden lines the collar on their
necks will strangle them to death hence
the students reluctantly return inside
the house ayaki goes to Yuki's room and
it's revealed that the two girls have
played the werewolf game before and
knowing that they can't trust each other
in this hostile environment they lie
about their identities at night the
players gather at the main hall to vote
but even after 10 minutes of staring
they don't utter a word so with time
running out a smart guy named shigamoto
breaks the silence and votes for kodai
the most talkative and arrogant member
of the group he mentions that ever since
they arrived here kodai has been acting
very bully-ish something which a
werewolf would do or maybe a [ __ ]
panicked kodai gets up from his seat and
reveals that he is actually the bouncer
but no one believes him instead almost
all of them vote for him as the clock
hits eight suddenly the caller around
kodai's neck tightens and he dies a
gruesome death much to everyone's horror
when the clock passes 10 pm Yuki
Ventures out of her room in search of a
weapon revealing that she is one of the
werewolves as she waits in a kitchen she
is soon joined by the second werewolf
kentaru the two immediately get talking
and here it is revealed that they both
have also played the game before 30
minutes pass by but the third werewolf
doesn't show up so Yuki and kintaru
decide to go on the hunt by themselves
they initially think of killing the fox
ayaki but end up choosing shigamoto as
he is a smart guy who can easily
manipulate others this became evident
when he orchestrated kodai's death
kantaru claiming that he is nervous
hands the knife to Yuki and tells her to
get the job done she obliges but when
the werewolves barge inside the room
shigamoto jumps out of his bed and puts
up a fight but suddenly his collar
strangely tightens causing him to fall
on the ground unconscious nevertheless
Yuki grabs a chair and smashes
shigamoto's head giving him a quick
death the next day the remaining
students discover shigamoto's dead body
and gather to decide their next move
suddenly one of the nerdy students Joe
comes running down he claims to be the
prophet and proceeds to tell the role he
discovered last night however the senior
most member Ricky tells him to wait and
asks all the self-proclaimed prophets
ayaki Joe and kintaru to share their
information at the exact same time to
see if there are any contradictions that
would help find out who might be lying
ayaki claims that her crush yosuke is a
villager while the werewolf kintaru
points at a silent girl miyari and
claims that she is a villager but on the
contrary the nerd Joe explains that he
checked shigamoto's identity last night
and found out that he was the fox he
claims that as the rule states if a
prophet discovers the role of the fox
then whoever has the fox card will die
and since shigamoto died yesterday it
indicates that Joe is telling the truth
and that he is the real Prophet however
nobody believes him and Reiki counter
questions by asking that if shikamoto
was killed by the prophet then who did
the werewolves attack last night this
catches Joe off guard and he quickly
changes the subject by accusing the
other two prophets of being werewolves
sadly this only backfires on him as the
cunning kentaru accuses him of changing
identities because he is one of the
werewolves that night the second voting
session begins and The Silent Girl mieri
speaks for the first time she suggests
that they shouldn't vote to execute any
of the self-proclaimed prophets yet
because they don't know who's telling
the truth and if they make another other
prediction the group might be able to
find out who's a werewolf it makes sense
but the girl has an ulterior motive
since the self-proclaimed prophets
claimed that she and yosuke are both
villagers they should have immunity from
the voting tonight the players agree
with her logic and decide to find
someone else to vote on ayaki uses this
opportunity to take revenge against Anna
a girl who was seen flirting with her
Crush yosuke ayaki tells everyone that
she's suspicious Savannah here because
she's been quiet for the whole game this
terrifies Anna and she explains that
she's only being quiet because she's
trying to understand the game yosuke
also comes to her defense saying he
should also be suspected for being quiet
but ayaki points out she's already
revealed him as a villager sadly with
time running out all the students turn
on Anna causing her to die a painful
death at midnight the werewolves meet up
in the kitchen again Yuki and kintaru
are worried that the third werewolf
still hasn't shown up and they wonder if
Anna was the other Wolf the two wolves
then decide to make Reiki their next
Target they choose him as he is the
wisest among everyone and has started
Riley up the other students as of late
soon the werewolves break into his door
prompting the frightened Reiki to escape
out of his window sadly he crosses the
Forbidden line because of which his
collar activates and instantly kills him
the werewolves are about to head back to
their rooms when Yuki comes up with an
idea to find the third wolf she suggests
testing the locks of every room has only
the werewolves doors open at night she
checks all the doors and finds them all
locked kintaru checks the last door and
finds it open but he lies to Yuki that
it is locked too claiming that the third
wolf must have already died the next day
the students find reiki's corpse and
they gather around to discuss their next
move there kintaru tells everyone that
last night as the prophet he discovered
that ayaka is the werewolf this catches
ayaka by surprise and she scrambles to
defend herself when kintaro continues to
press her for a confession she changes
her story and claims that she was
actually the medium all along she
explains that she thought the bouncer
wouldn't protect the medium so she
pretended to be the prophet to survive
however even ayaka's crush is skeptical
of her and he thinks the real medium
might have died already but surprisingly
the nerd Joe strongly believes that with
eight players left the medium is still
more likely to be alive he then goes on
to claim that as the prophet he
discovered that Yuki is the real
werewolf much to her surprise Yuki
insists she's innocent and quickly
shifts the accusation towards ayaka with
no perfect strategy to bring out the
werewolves the group agrees to a plan
that night they will tie up all the
suspects to their bed and lock them in
their rooms until morning if someone
still dies it means that there's another
werewolf kantaru panics and he argues
that it's not a good idea because the
villagers won't be able to defend
themselves against the Wolves however
his arguments make him look guilty and
the suspects are forced to accept the
deal after a while at the voting session
kintaru tries to convince everyone that
the real medium is dead and ayaka is the
werewolf yosuke agrees with him as ayaka
has already lied about being the prophet
soon things get out of control and Joe
confronts kintaru for accusing him of
being a phony Prophet with everyone just
distracted the clock strikes eight and
everyone's collar starts to tighten
around their necks causing them to
slowly suffocate left with no choice
they all quickly vote selecting the most
unpopular player at the moment kintaru
everyone's caller finally loosens up
except for kintaru who dies a painful
death that night Yuki ayaka and her
friend Ozawa are tied up in their
respective beds now with kintaru God
Yuki has to take charge and kill someone
or else all the werewolves will
automatically die out as she struggles
to entire self she finds a knife under
her pillow left by the third wolf who
apparently is still alive she uses it to
free herself and storms into ozawa's
room Yuki looks for any weapons in a
room but when she doesn't find any she
becomes sure that Ozawa is just a
villager however since the poor girl
already knows too much she has to be
silenced Yuki brutally finishes her off
but in the process ends up getting a
massive cut on her face scared she
immediately goes to the washroom to
recuperate as she is washing the blood
off her face she realizes that the other
players will surely find out that she is
the wolf because of her wound suddenly
someone walks in it's the third werewolf
the next morning ayaka and the others
learned that Ozawa lost her life leaving
only six people now Yuki also arrives
and everyone notices the massive cut on
her cheek left with no choice she admits
that she's a werewolf oh come on she
could have done better than that however
to save herself she also claims to be
the last werewolf and that the Fox is
still alive now if the other
participants decide to vote her out the
fox will automatically win resulting in
everyone's deaths once again Joe claims
that he killed the fox shigamoto using
his profitabilities but Yuki knows that
he's lying since he was the one who
killed shigamoto later that day Yuki
confronts ayaka and accuses her of being
a fox with no way out of the situation
ayaka finally admits that she lied about
being a medium and as the two girls are
discussing miyari shows up revealing
that she's the third werewolf she
reveals that she had been hiding all
this time on the advice of kintaro it
turns out that even miyari played this
game before along with kintaru and
yosuke she then confidently claims that
yosuke will take her side when she tells
him that ayaka is the fox now with the
two werewolves and yosuke voting against
her ayaka has absolutely no chance of
surviving despite the odds against her
she goes to the roof to convince her
Crush yosuke she asks him if there's
anyone in this game that he cares for
yosuke replies that miyari is a close
friend of his completely oblivious to
the fact that she is one of the Wolves
ayaka once again inquires if he would
believe her if she tells him that miari
is the wolf to which yosuke says no
hearing this ayaka realizes there's
nothing she can do to change his mind
and leaves with her heart broken when
she returns to the building she is
surprised to see Yuki waiting for her in
a shocking turn of events Yuki reveals
that she wants ayaka to win the game she
says that she can't continue living
after slaughtering so many innocent
friends in this game ayaka is still left
in disbelief but nonetheless she
promises that she will never give up
that night everyone gathers for the
fight final vote ayaka continues to
pretend to be the medium and accuses a
girl named saiki of being the fox
because Joe is believed to be the
prophet and yosuke is believed to be a
villager the group then casts their
final vote two people vote for ayaka one
votes for Yuki and three people vote for
saiki the Villager it turns out Yuki
stood by her words and voted for saiki
instead of ayaka which saved the
latter's life now with saiki Dad the
number of villagers werewolves equal at
two each as per the rules the werewolves
should be victorious but since the Fox
is still alive
ayaka wins it suddenly the TV turns on
telling them that the fox has survived
and has won and in the blink of an eye
everyone's callers start to tighten
ayaka can only watch as her friends die
right before her eyes finally after days
of Terror she has won the game and also
a million dollars the movie ends as
ayaka takes her color off and burns her
Fox card subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out say thank
you for watching